hi in this video we will see how
computers talk
before we do that i would like to give
you an analogy of how people
talk in this room we have john bob and
mary
and when jon wants to talk to mary he
says hi mary this is john
how are you doing now when they're in
the same room they are
sharing the same medium which is the air
and all
all of them bob and mary hear to this
message
but only mary responds because it's
addressed to mary in the same way when
computers want to talk
they share a medium in this example
all these three computers are sharing a
cable this is how
networks were built in the past so you
have
nic cards for each of these computers
and they have their own mac addresses
now let's say if a wants to talk to b
what a does is it sends a message
to b which looks similar to this
b you know you use the mac address to
address b
this is a talking and here is my message
how are you doing
now when this message is put on this
medium
everybody on this medium can listen to
it so in this case
b and c can listen to this message
now what happens is when c looks at this
message it sees that it's addressed to b
so it just silently ignores it and b
when it gets this message
it sees that oh this message is
addressed to me so let me reply
and when it decides to reply what b does
is
i want to know who is talking so it
looks at the original message and sees
oh it's a who is
talking so it says hey a
this is b and the actual message i'm
doing good
that's how computers talk